menos muertes que en otras olas de
contagios es una de las conclusiones
preliminares a las que han llegado
varios médicos y científicos
sudafricanos sobre la gravedad de la
enfermedad causada por la variante
omicron en el país africano por el
momento prácticamente todo apunta que se
trata de una enfermedad más leve son los
primeros días y necesitamos obtener los
datos finales a menudo las
hospitalizaciones y las muertes ocurren
más tarde y sólo llevamos dos semanas en
esta ola el instituto nacional de
enfermedades transmisibles de sudáfrica
también brinda otros datos sobre los
efectos de omicron en la población el 30
por ciento de los hospitalizados por
kobe 19 en las últimas semanas han
estado gravemente enfermos un porcentaje
de menos de la mitad que durante las
primeras semanas de otras oleadas de
contagios las estancias en los
hospitales también han sido más cortas
en un promedio de 2.8 días en
comparación con los 8 que se registraban
en el pasado sólo el 3 por ciento de los
pacientes hospitalizados por kobe 19 han
muerto un porcentaje menor que el 20% de
otros brotes según el doctor sudafricano
un bentley la gran parte de los
pacientes tienen síntomas más leves
parecido a la gripe con dolores
corporales y tos sin embargo los casos
siguen aumentando aceleradamente jones
omicron ha impulsado el resurgimiento de
los casos de kobe 19 en sudáfrica
con algo más de 90 mil casos a nivel
nacional desde el 7 de noviembre hasta
el 4 de diciembre de 2021
a pesar de los datos recogidos hasta el
momento sobre la gravedad de omicron los
expertos piden no bajar la guardia pues
el aumento drástico de los casos podría
saturar el sistema hospitalario y así
provocar más muertes